[Aplausos]
[Música]
cada vez que un gobierno latinoamericano
quiere hablar de política exterior y
desarrollo termina siempre hablando de
integración regional por eso no podemos
extrañarnos de que latinoamérica tenga
tres elementos característicos el fútbol
las revoluciones y los organismos de
integración regional en serio no es
broma en las últimas décadas han
aparecido tantos organismos regionales
que es casi imposible saber qué misión
tiene cada uno además claro está de
gastar dinero en sedes viajes y
funcionarios unasur mercosur albacar y
con celac allowed y la comunidad andina
el sica el sela el grupo del río por
supuesto también está la organización de
estados americanos y la verdad seguro
que nos dejamos unos cuantos en el
tintero vamos que a tenor de tantos
organismos de todos los tipos y colores
bien podríamos pensar que en
latinoamérica es la zona del mundo en
que los países se llevan mejor que es
más fácil hacer negocios entre ellos y
donde sus gobiernos trabajan codo con
codo verdad pues lo siento pero nada de
eso una cosa son las intenciones y los
los políticos y otra muy distinta la
realidad y es que amigos todos estos
organismos nacieron con grandes
objetivos pero prácticamente podemos
decir que todos se quedaron en nada
si hablamos de desarrollo o de
integración económica y política en
américa latina' se crean nuevas
instituciones pero no se aclara que se
va a hacer con las previamente
existentes es una permanente huida hacia
adelante y un constante añadido de
siglas y acrónimos a la voluminosa sopa
de letras existentes fijaos a pesar de
todos estos procesos de integración el
comercio entre los países de la región
es anormalmente pequeños
los datos son contundentes la parte de
las exportaciones que permanecen dentro
de la región se ha mantenido
prácticamente invariable en un nivel de
apenas el 20 por ciento mucho más bajo
que el que encontramos en otras zonas
del mundo en mejor prueba de lo
artificial y de lo poco productivos que
resultan todos estos organismos
luego veremos en detalle el caso bueno
más bien la decepción o el fracaso de
mercosur pero ya se adelantó que es muy
posible que en toda esta falta de
integración real esté el origen de
algunos de los grandes problemas de la
región
[Música]
la eterna promesa
si américa latina' amigos es una región
fantástica es tremendamente rica en
recursos naturales cuenta con una
biodiversidad y una variedad climática
impresionante y tiene un peso muy
importante en cualquier ranking que
recoja los lugares más bonitos de la
tierra
sin embargo económicamente las cosas no
pintan tan bien a pesar de todos estos
formidables recursos y su gran potencial
la región se ha quedado atrás en
términos de crecimiento económico
comparemos por ejemplo el caso del país
más rico a día de hoy de toda
latinoamérica chile pues bien creo que
decir que chile lo ha hecho
relativamente bien en las últimas
décadas no le puede extrañar a nadie
verdad pues a pesar de ello atentos a
este gráfico
[Música]
ojo hemos tomado el país más rico de
toda latinoamérica y lo hemos comparado
con corea del sur que no es precisamente
el país más rico de asia oriental pues
bien el contraste es evidente en los
años 60 chile era un país pobre pero
bastante más rico que corea del sur
hoy las cosas sin embargo son muy
distintas
podemos fijarnos también en argentina-
que históricamente fue el país más rico
de latinoamérica con la excepción de
cuba fijaos qué ocurre si comparamos su
evolución con la de españa por ejemplo
[Música]
i
pues bien es muy probable que una de las
causas de este menor empuje sea
precisamente la poca integración
comercial y el exceso de proteccionismo
y burocracia que ha padecido
históricamente la región
es decir mucho consejo mucho acuerdo
mucho foro pero a la hora de la verdad
nada de nada pero he esperado un momento
hace unos años se puso en marcha un
proyecto de integración nuevo y
completamente distinto a todos los demás
y amigos todo apunta a que no sólo
estamos ante el primer proyecto de
auténtico éxito en la región sino
también ante una oportunidad que puede
cambiar el destino de toda latinoamérica
hablamos como no de la alianza del
pacífico
[Música]
la alianza del pacífico
en abril de 2011 amigos de visual
político chile colombia méxico y perú
formaron la llamada alianza del pacífico
su misión conseguir por fin una
integración que permita la libre
circulación de mercancías capitales y
por supuesto también personas todo ello
con el objetivo de estimular claro el
crecimiento el desarrollo y la
competitividad de sus economías
nuestros países expresan el 55 por
ciento de las exportaciones
latinoamericanas esta no es una
integración romántica una integración
poética es una integración realista ante
el mundo y hacia el mundo pues bien
dicho y hecho aunque aún queda mucho por
hacer
desde entonces el desarrollo del
proyecto ha sido cómo decirlo muy
relevante
[Música]
en apenas seis años estos cuatro países
han suprimido el 92 por ciento de los
aranceles y han puesto fecha para acabar
con el resto y ojo porque la integración
comercial no se queda ahí también han
simplificado y facilitado los trámites
aduaneros y burocráticos especialmente
los referentes a las reglas de origen
que son un ancla enorme para la región
fijaos hasta ahora si un productor de
colombia utilizaba proveedores peruanos
luego para vender su producción a méxico
no podía beneficiarse del acuerdo de
libre comercio entre colombia y mexico
una locura
pues bien ahora cualquier producto
creado en alguno de los cuatro países
miembros es un producto de la alianza y
puede moverse libremente y ojo aquí no
acaba todo para nada también se han
eliminado los requisitos de visado lo
que por ejemplo ha permitido duplicar el
flujo de visitantes entre estos cuatro
países y luego muy importante se ha
avanzado bastante en la integración
financiera de hecho estos cuatro países
han creado el mila el mercado integrado
latinoamericano que ojo es ya el mercado
bursátil más grande de toda
latinoamérica esto tarde o temprano
facilitará que los grandes capitales se
fijen en estos mercados
[Música]
y aún hay más entre otras muchas
iniciativas los países de la alianza
trabajan conjuntamente para
promocionarse en ferias internacionales
han empezado a compartir embajadas en
países africanos y asiáticos y han
decidido negociar en bloque acuerdos de
libre comercio o acuerdos preferenciales
lo han comenzado a hacer por ejemplo con
nueva zelanda australia canadá y
singapur australia y nueva zelanda
comienzan conversaciones comerciales con
la alianza del pacífico en otras
palabras estos cuatro países están
construyendo poco a poco un mercado
integrado que ojo no será precisamente
poca cosa
estamos hablando amigos de más de 214
millones de consumidores y un pib
combinado que convierte a esta alianza
en una de las ocho economías más grandes
de todo el planeta
[Música]
la alianza del pacífico representa en
latinoamérica el 50 por ciento de todas
las exportaciones y más del 40 por
ciento de toda la inversión extranjera
y podemos decir que si la lealtad el
pacífico continúa su buena marcha en
poco tiempo podremos considerarla la
gran fuerza la gran potencia de toda
latinoamérica pero para comprender un
poco mejor todos estos logros cosechados
en tan sólo seis años fijémonos en el
otro gran bloque de la región mercosur
el ocaso de mercosur
el mercosur fue creado en 1991 por
brasil argentina uruguay y paraguay con
la intención de crear un gran mercado
integrado entre estos cuatro países pues
bien como decirlo los objetivos eran muy
ambiciosos pero los avances han sido
mucho más discretos que es una prueba
fijaos el comercio intra-mercosur dentro
del mercosur representa hoy menos del 13
por ciento del comercio total de sus
países integrantes en 1995 era casi el
20 por ciento es decir que lejos de
promover el comercio entre sus miembros
casi podríamos decir que mercosur lo ha
debilitado y es que en los últimos años
mercosur ha pasado de ser un proceso de
integración a ser una especie de cómo
decirlo escudo proteccionista durante la
última década el comercio entre los
miembros del mercosur ha crecido más
lentamente que entre los países de
américa latina que no pertenecen a él e
incluso menos que entre los miembros del
mercosur y otros países latinoamericanos
pero porque no funcionan pues
fundamentalmente porque
no hay compromiso mercosur es
teóricamente un proceso de integración
económica pero las salvedades y las
excepciones son tantas que al final en
la realidad no hay ni libre tránsito de
bienes ni de servicios al final mercosur
se ha convertido en un organismo tan
político como inoperante fijaos o un
buen ejemplo lo podemos encontrar en la
frontera entre argentina y uruguay en
teoría las fronteras internas no
deberían existir y las mercancías
podrían moverse libremente sin embargo
la realidad es muy diferente y entre
aduanas inspecciones y burocracia y el
paso de un camión de mercancías por la
frontera entre uruguay y argentina puede
retrasarse más de 24 horas
todo esto amigos de visual política ha
provocado que uruguay haya pedido
formalmente convertirse en miembro
asociado de la alianza del pacífico y no
sólo eso el cambio político en argentina
y en brasil ha hecho que estos gobiernos
acepten que mercosur tal y como hoy está
no vale prácticamente para nada al
mercado común nunca llegamos la unión
aduanera está
totalmente destrozada y la zona de libre
comercio tampoco funciona y el mercosur
está en un estado de inacción
prácticamente total por eso macri ha
decidido acercarse también a la alianza
del pacífico y buscar así estrechar
lazos entre ambos procesos de
integración la gran pregunta es lograr a
esta alianza impulsar el cambio en
mercosur desde luego sería una gran
noticia para toda la región
[Música]
los pumas del pacífico'
pues bien llegados a este punto nos
queda una última pregunta porque la
alianza del pacífico a diferencia de
todos los demás procesos si parece estar
funcionando pues muy probablemente tenga
que ver que los llamados pumas del
pacífico chile perú colombia y méxico
que por cierto en los últimos años han
sido las economías más dinámicas de
latinoamerica compartan una misma misión
todos estos países parecen tener claro
que para crecer y desarrollarse
hay que producir y comerciar con el
resto del mundo por eso no es extraño
que según el banco mundial estos pumas
sean los países de la región donde más
fácil resulta hacer negocios o que sean
los países con más acuerdos comerciales
firmados con el resto del mundo
en fin amigos la alianza del pacífico
representa una de las mejores
oportunidades para que latinoamérica
aspire a convertirse en la nueva región
de moda puede que estemos ante el
nacimiento de una gran potencia
económica pero ahora turno para ti
crees que mercosur debe seguir los pasos
de la alianza del pacífico déjanos tu
respuesta como siempre en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha gustado el vídeo de la like y
suscríbete a visual politics si aún no
lo has hecho recuerda es gratis un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]